les cotillons c'est quoi ton job j'ai
commencé dans le design et maintenant je
pense qu'on peut dire le chanteur forme
un gérant voulait savoir si les ampoules
s'allumer mais ouais mais j'ai pas les
prix je peux aller présenter libre rita
dit quand on était avec le ministre des
ptt tout à l'heure que tu étais un
performeur alors c'est comme ça que sa
façon c'est pas le problème partout où
je vais ça devienne une performance je
dois dire que j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
billets comme ça c'est mon ambition
c'est vraiment sûr que c'est bidon ces
nouveaux outils qu on est dessus mais
qu'est ce que tu as là mais c'est un ami
qui m'a donné envie de moi ton club que
tellement bien marché le tabou l'année
dernière les gens disaient qui est pas
mal extasié quand même c'était bien
parce que ce sont les gens qui sait tout
ce qu'il voulait il crié ils se
désintéressent des français et chaque
fois j'étais d'accord temps en temps
c'était vraiment 5 pas les gens comme
boy george comme jean paul gaultier
tobam piqué pas mal
d ça te fais pas chier d'être des
pauvres alors qu'ils sont quand même je
serai quelques toiles moi je suis très
flatté parce que j'adore boy georges dor
jean paul gaultier façon quand on est
limité c'est la meilleure façon d'être
c'est pas un pee wee herman anglais je
pense tous différents oui à beaucoup
plus de références avec le passé je mets
mes lunettes parce que vraiment est très
brillant tendances et les beuveries
nous on préfère appeler madame bovary me
fais comme tu veux
des pas de problème pour moi de ton ami
trop jeune trop yann six pattes
c'est vrai qu'il a essayé de se couper
le lobe de l'oreille en fait il voulait
ce coupé l'oreille complètement mais il
avait des mauvais ciseaux aïda une vache
malade il a juste plus couper le loc
c'est pas le dernier painchaud père je
pense effectivement que je représente
l'esprit du je suis très content tu
détestes les yeux l'espoir yuppies yafei
ap j'ai pas je pense que mon prochain
look ce sera peut-être le noter au pied
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu